explore mysterious toons battle hordes
of mummies and on earth ancient weapons
in Xia Mars latest monthly update mummy
see mummy - this massive update features
six all new maps spanning both co-op and
competitive modes in land of the dead
explore creepy Egyptian ruins while
fending off hordes of them mummified
undead that is of course if you can
survive the traps that'll slice / Vernon
puree you into a delicious mercenary
smoothie discover the secrets of the
necrotic necropolis where players will
work together to fight off waves of
mummies as you unlock new areas of the
tomb attack it on advanced or expert
difficulty to take on the all-powerful
Khufu the tyrant Pharaoh in shangri-la a
peaceful mausoleum has transformed into
an infested zombie playground use
environmental traps to fend off the
ancient Undead which will need more than
a few traps to face off against a giant
of terracotta demon statues
while the pvp fans out there prepare to
throw down as mummy see mummy doom
debuts three all new competitive maps
urban sprawl puts players in the tight
quarters of the city scrambling for
limited cover sand trap will test your
line of sight as you fight along the
Nile River and Mean Streets will require
some serious stop and pop strategies to
beat your opponents in addition to the
six all new maps get excited for a brand
new competitive mode blood diamonds open
for a limited time kill members of the
opposing team to collect gems and return
them to drop-off zones to score points
the team with the most points at the end
will be crowned with winners new
business updates EMR adds all new gear
costumes and weapons including all tiny
classics like that winchester 1897 plus
for ancient weapons straight from the
tombs imbued with bonus undead killing
powers whether you're into killing
mummies ancient statues or each other
mummy see mummy doom adds crazy tomb
raiding action into zmr so play now and
kill every thing